CBS News confirmed an arrest is expected
as soon as today in the criminal
investigation of Russian meddling in
last year's presidential election the
charges are under seal and have not been
made public Special Counsel Robert
Muller is looking into possible
collusion between Trump campaign
associates and Russian interests Jeff
Pegues is in Washington with who could
be arrested today Jeff good morning good
morning CBS News has confirmed with
multiple sources that a federal grand
jury has approved charges in connection
with the Russia investigation and the
sealed indictment is expected be made
public sometime today when that happens
it will signal a new phase in the Russia
investigation as special counsel Robert
Muller moves to prosecute suspects
important people have been questioned
he's not screwing around it's really
important what the charge is it's really
important who the person being charged
is on Sunday lawmakers highlighted the
seriousness of a federal grand jury
approving charges in connection with the
Russia investigation there are two
people I think just for press reporting
that it is likely to be either Mike
Flynn or Paul man afford we have no
relationship was the Trump campaign
chairman between May and August of 2016
but prior to the campaign he was a
prominent Washington lobbyist his
dealings in Ukraine have come under
scrutiny because of his ties to Russian
oligarchs connected to the Kremlin and
Russian President Vladimir Putin mana
Ford along with Carter Page who was a
foreign policy adviser for the Trump
campaign the president's son Donald
Trump jr. Jared Kushner the president's
son-in-law and former national security
adviser Michael Flynn have all been
under scrutiny Flynn was fired in
February after misleading the vice
president about his contacts with
Russian officials former US Attorney
Preet Bharara says the first arrest is
likely to be someone who has information
that can advance the overall
investigation prosecutors like those in
my former office and those that work in
Bob Muller's office now try to see who
they can bring charges against first and
see if they have information about
someone else Manta Ford's attorneys say
they have not been informed that their
client has been indicted while Flynn's
attorneys did not respond to our request
for comment
as far as who leaked the indictment
congressman Gowdy says it should not be
overlooked that someone violated the law
by disclosing grand jury material Gail
all right Jeff thank you very much